[Music]
they twinkle they Inspire they bring
alive the night sky thousands of stars
bright enough to be seen on a clear
night but in reality there are more than
100 billion stars just in our Milky Way
[Music]
galaxy and the deeper we look into space
the harder it is to see past so many
stars the glare from all of those Suns
blinds us from seeing what else is is
really out
there when you're trying to look for
earthlike planets next to sunlike stars
in those cases the reflected light from
the planet is uh about 10 billion times
fainter than the light of the star it's
a tremendous Challenge and this is why
star shades are really compelling as a
way of addressing this
[Music]
challenge aerospace engineer Manon Arya
has has been working for years on a
galactic puzzle how to block staright in
a universe that contains up to one
septian Stars a solution says the
assistant professor at Stanford
University lies in an ancient form of
art folding paper origami teaches us how
to fold very large thin sheets into very
small spaces and that's exactly what
space engineers need we met with mannon
at the offworld bar a space themed venue
in Toronto to learn more about how
origami can reveal worlds we know are
out there but cannot see the reason we
need origami for space
applications is because we want to
launch structures in space that are just
amazingly big so being able to fold
these structures such that they fit
neatly within our rocket and then unfold
when they get to space his Fascination
began when he was a kid born and raised
in New Delhi India man and dreamt of one
day going into space
you had dreams of being an astronaut as
a child was it a possibility oh gosh no
I've met people who are qualified to be
astronauts and I've met some astronauts
I am not of that flavor of person
because I like to sit and think for a
long time before I take actions I'm
terribly not useful in emergencies did
you think that uh if I can't be an
astronaut there's a way that I can find
my way in here I had dreams that maybe
they'd be fantastic if I could go to
NASA and maybe contribute there I never
actually thought it would happen but it
kind of
did it would be a long journey to
realize his dreams in 2003 mannon and
his family moved to Canada where he
attended high school and then the
University of Toronto it was there he
became enamored with studying
structures I became fascinated with
these kinds of spacecraft called solar
sales which are spacecraft that unfold
these large Sals that you used the
pressure of sunlight to generate thrust
light bouncing off objects produces
thrust the problem is the pressure of
sunlight that the thrust you get from
the solar sails depends on how big your
sale is and for these tiny small
satellites trying to fit a very large
sale into these small satellites
required you know some interesting
engineering and that's what led me to
origami the problem of trying to fold
these I don't know 10x 10 meter sails
into a spacecraft the size of a bread
box mannon calls it the suitcase problem
but instead of packing clothes it's how
much expandable technology you can cram
into a small Space
Capsule this is the mirror Ori
fold the Japanese art of paper folding
has a long history dating back thousands
of years now its principles are being
used in many different fields including
Aerospace
it was really in the' 60s and' 7s when
mathematicians and academics got
interested in the art of origami and
since that time they've developed this
fantastic tool set of ideas that were
available to me that I could just pick
up and run with mannon brought his
interest in origami to Caltech the
California Institute of Technology
Caltech manages NASA's jet propulsion
laboratory known as JPL and after
graduating Manon went to work on Star
shade star shade is a u fantastic
application of kind of origami
engineering a star shade is a mechanism
by which we can block out the light of a
star so we can observe faint planets
that are orbiting that star what would
be really fantastic is if you could take
pictures of these planets of these
exoplanets the challenge is these
planets orbit these bright pesky things
called Stars which are much much
brighter than the planet star shade is a
way where we we can block out that glare
so we can see those faint planets next
to it tell me how that works it's almost
as if uh you've taken a shade and put it
in front of the camera the telescope in
this case and the shade blocks out
exactly the light of the star while
letting the light of the planet pass by
the side of the shade at the side of the
shade exactly it's not coming through it
yeah it's like if you're trying to look
at something really close to the Sun and
you put your thumb up to block out the
sunlight so you can see let's say a bird
or something like that flying with a
Space Telescope the star shade would use
thrusters to put itself in a position to
block a star and allow the telescope to
capture images according to Manon when
fully unfurled star shade would be
roughly the size of a baseball diamond
but to get into space it needs to fit
into a rocket about 5 m in diameter
that's where origami comes in how big is
it going to be when it's in its folded
up stage maybe the size of an SUV how
are you coming along
oh fantastically I should point out star
shade is not an official NASA Mission it
is a a technology that we're developing
such that we have in our back pockets
for future
missions NASA has had success using
origami already the powerful James web
telescope's main mirror and sun shield
had to be folded up to be launched into
[Music]
space and the pictures it's sending back
can only be inspiration for Star shade
[Music]
as for mannon his curiosity with the
traditional art has only grown the
motivation behind making structures like
these was to make foldable robots for
space exploration now in his lab at
Stanford he's applying the same
techniques to engineering biomedical
devices and
Robotics from creating Innovations to
discovering far away worlds much of what
Manon is doing today may lead to
unimagined breakthroughs years from now
parts of me that wish that my work would
have more immediate impact at the same
time I'm satisfied with the idea that
I'm doing work that is foundational for
the next generation of Technologies the
things that I'm working
on may not come to light or if they do
they may come to light a long time from
now but so far oh so far it's been a
wild ride it's been
[Music]
fantastic